-I'm hanging out with
Jason Momoa.
And we are about to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is going...
What in the world is going on?
We're about to have a rematch
of a game we call --
[ Engine revving ]
Oh, my gosh.
"Water War."
Now, here's how it works.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so happy
you're not in studio.
This is -- You're too cocky.
Here's how it works.
We're going to play the
card game War,
where we flip over a card.
Whoever has
the higher card wins.
If you lose, you get a glass of
water thrown in your face.
Throwing water in my face
on behalf of Jason
will be Tariq Trotter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And who will be
throwing in my face
is my beautiful family on "See."
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Hey, guys!
Welcome and thank you
for doing this.
Get him good.
Get him good, alright?
-You wish!
-Here we go.
I wish I could
take anything off. I can't.
Sure, I can.
Let me take off my...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
Alright.
-You see that, man?
That's how I used to do it back
in my stripper days.
Just come out and strip
in three seconds and leave.
Angrily tossing my clothes.
Alright.
-Alright, here we go.
-You ready for this, bud?
-I'm ready.
-1, 2, 3.
Ooh, it's war!
-War!
-It's a war already.
You know what that means?
That means pitcher.
That means it's a pitcher
of water, whoever --
Now you got to do three --
-Oh, man!
-Three cards off to the side
and then flip the fourth one.
Already, already this is a war!
Ready? Here we go.
-[ Laughs ] Come on, baby.
-1, 2...
[ Drumroll ]
-1, 2, 3.
-Now flip.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah!
-Boom!
-Oh, come on!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! I'm so happy!
Mwah! Mwah! Mwah!
Get that pitcher up.
-Alright, let me get in here.
-Get that pitcher up!
Come on!
You only get
one chance to do this!
Look at this!
-Alright, go ahead.
-Go for it! Come on, pal!
-Aaaah!
-Yeah!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, I like her. Oh, I like her!
That was fantastic.
-That's my daughter.
-That was great.
I love this game.
-That's my daughter,
just like Lola.
-That was a great --
-Too strong.
-Well, we got to
go to commercial now.
Thank you so much for
coming on the...
[ Laughter ]
Alright, buddy. Here we go.
Ready, pal?
-Ready?
-Alright.
1, 2, 3.
Oh, yes!
-Queen, baby.
-No! Are you kidding me?
Queen over Jacks?
Alright.
-Ooh! Come here.
Come here, girl!
-Tariq, be cool, bud.
-Here we go.
-Yep.
-Aah!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, wow!
[ Laughs ]
Wait. Is that the way it works?
'Cause if that's
the way it works, Tariq,
we're going to have fun, man.
[ Laughter ]
Change the rules.
Alright, here we go.
-Alright, here we go.
Ready?
-Yeah.
-Alright, ready?
1, 2, 3.
Ooh, God, not...
-You got 2? Oh!
Tariq.
-Ready?
-Yeah. I lost, yep.
-Aah!
-You're yelling "Ha!"
Alright.
Why are you doing --
Why are you --
-I love you, boy!
-Alright, ready?
-I'm ready. Ready?
-1, 2...
1 --
-Come on, man.
Ready?
-Ready? Yeah.
1, 2, 3.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yes!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
Aah!
-Oh, wow! A little payback.
Look at that mad face. Yes!
Then slammed it down.
Alright, this is a barn burner.
Ready? 1, 2, 3.
9. Alright.
-9!
-You won.
You won, you won, you won.
Tariq.
-Aah!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah, I guess it's fun, right?
Alright, bud.
1, 2, 3.
-[Bleep]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get him good!
-Yep, here we go.
[Bleep]
-Whoa! [ Laughs ]
Where'd she get that bucket?
-My wife, everyone!
-Where did she get that
giant bucket?
You are awesome!
Where did that come from?
Hopefully we don't have
one here.
Alright, here we go.
It's a tie game.
It's anyone's game.
Here we go. Ready?
1, 2, 3.
-Here we go. Tie game. Come on.
-King, baby!
-Ace, baby! Ace!
-Oh! No way!
-Ace!
I win, right?
Yes, I win! Aces!
[ Dinging ]
-Yeah, you win!
-Judges say I won that one.
-Alright.
-Alright, bud.
-Jimmy,
I will see you for "Aquaman 2."
It's on.
Paybacks are a bitch!
-I remain the champ.
That's my boy right there.
Jason Momoa, everybody.
Season 2 of the show "See"
will premiere on August 27th
on Apple TV+.
Rose Byrne joins us
after the break!
Stick around, everybody!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪